[Musique]
comment vous allez j'espère vous allez
plutôt bien la grosse patate comme on
dit chez nous je suis très heureux
aujourd'hui de pouvoir dont trois pour
vous parler d'un produit qui est super
sympa j'ai reçu il ya quelques jours
c'est la microsoft surface laptop gosset
le tout nouvel ordinateur de microsoft
et surtout andy qui est vachement
intéressante parce qu'il ya se
positionner sur un segment on n'a pas
trop l'habitude de retrouver microsoft
au niveau de son ordinateur on est sur
un segment a nettement moins de 1000
euros on est sur le premier tarif à 629
euros j'ai tout noter là dessus ça c'est
très très précis 629 euros est en fait
microsoft surface laptop go non un petit
peu rallonge et là il est super
surprenant c'est vraiment un tout petit
or dit il est tout mignon d'un tout
petit écran mais il est vachement bien
et il est vachement intéressant alors
qui fera pas tout il vous fera pas à
boire à manger la soupe tout ce que vous
voulez mais pas contre ce qu il le fait
il le fait plutôt bien et ce qui est
très important avec son ordinateur là
avant même de l'acheter de se
positionner
et bien c'est de savoir s'il est fait
pour vous à qui il est destiné qu'est ce
qui vous permet de faire et qu'est-ce
qu'il vous permet pas de faire part ça
vous en douterez à un peu moins de 700
euros on ne peut pas tout faire je vais
tout vous dire tout vous détailler et
pour que à la fin de cette vidéo vous
sachiez tous sur ce nouvel ordinateur
microsoft le microsoft surface laptop
goût ici on a tout petit ordinateur avec
un capot en aluminium et un châssis en
plastique microsoft préférera nous
parler de système de résines en
composites polycarbonate avec fibre de
verre et 30 % de contenu recyclé post
consommation
bon c'est du plastique mais le toucher
vraiment agréable mais surtout on a un
ordi qu'il fait à peine 1 kg 110 grammes
pour une épaisseur de 15 69 mm il existe
en plusieurs couleurs le bleu glacier le
sable et le platine mois ses platines
que j'ai on s'en rend compte dès la
première ouverture le produit a vraiment
de supers finition à tel point que l'on
retourne sur sa fiche technique et on
regarde le prix pour vérifier qu'il
s'agit bien de ce produit qu'il s'agit
bien du bon prix 629 euros
c'est assez bluffant pour 629 euros
d'avoirs définition comme ça un châssis
qui est vraiment irréprochable qui sent
la solidité du système d'ouverture qui
est vraiment à la hauteur
un touché au niveau du clavier qui est
assez dingue on a vraiment une sensation
de douceur et à côté un peu veule ou
lorsqu'on vient taper sur ce clavier et
le trackpad est aussi assez précis à ses
standards ça peut paraître bête de vous
dire comme ça les niveaux de finition à
ce prix là est vraiment extrêmement
bluffant et surtout on a une vraie
sensation de douceur avec un très bon
retour de touche
ça c'est vraiment hyper agréable le
trackpad est aussi assez qualitatif on
pourra lui reprocher une taille qui est
un peu petit
on aurait pu espérer un poil plus grand
mais vu la taille du châssis rien de
bien des collants là dessus mais à 629
euros on va pas non plus tout avoir
est-ce que je vais venir reproché ici au
niveau de ce clavier c'est que vous
n'avez aucun rétro éclairage bon la
danse est conditions d'éclairage je vois
bien il a absolument aucun problème et
si vous retrouvez dans un amphi dans une
pièce un peu plus sombre ou le soir en
train de travailler dans votre lit avec
la lumière baissée
ça peut être un peu problématique qui
dit petit ordinateur dit forcément petit
écran et si vous avez un écran pixel
sense de 12,4 pouces d'un écran tactile
et ça c'est vachement agréable pour le
prix d'avoir effectivement un écran
tactile un écran que je trouvais assez
lumineux ont travaillé dans beaucoup de
conditions et bien écoutez scélérat
parfaitement bien et une résolution un
peu particulière de 1536 par 1024 à 141
pixels par pouce certes on n'est pas sur
du full hd ici mais une fois de plus on
est à moins de 700 euros et on pourra
pas tout avoir à ce prix là à côté de ça
l'écran tel qu'il est là je trouve de
bonne qualité agréable pour des usages
pour lesquels il est destiné mais ça je
vous en parle dans quelques instants
comme ça vous saurez tout pour savoir
s'il est fait pour vous ou pas du tout
le fait d'avoir un tactile à ce prix là
c'est vraiment bien et extrêmement mal
an et en terme d'expérience globale et
de visionnage il remplit extrêmement
bien son rôle petit bémol qu'on va
retrouver ici c'est au niveau des hauts
parleurs et du son en règle générale les
haut parleurs sont cachés par ici vous
ne les verrez pas microsoft nous propose
des haut parleurs omni sonic avec dolby
audio on va dire que qualité va être
plutôt bien et dans l'ensemble c'est pas
mauvais mais c'est un peu tout fait on
manque un peu de précision aux
spécialisations voilà alors ça va être
compliqué vous en rendre compte comme ça
au travers de mon micro mais dans
l'ensemble c'est convenable ne sais pas
non plus complètement dingue on va pas
voir trop extrêmement
pendant une très grosse patia lisation
n'aura néanmoins du son pour tout ce qui
m contenus multimédias ça fera l'affairé
y aura absolument aucun problème
une fois de plus on a moins de 700 euros
on arrête chose qui est qualitatif qui
fonctionnera bien mais tu vas pas non
plus faire des merveilles
et la bonne nouvelle au niveau audio
c'est que vous avez également une prise
jack vous retrouve également en termes
de connectique de l'usbc et de l'usb a
également un pource surface connect on a
certes ici juste minimum mais vous allez
pouvoir bien branché un hub en externe
si vous le souhaitez pour venir ajouter
différents ports est différent
connectique et surtout le port surface
connect vous servir à venir recharger
votre ordinateur très facilement vous le
branchez vous le positionner skis aussi
rassurant c'est que si jamais vous
l'arracher comme ça et bien vous n'allez
pas emmener votre ordinateur avec vous
il aimante et et tour sa position très
facilement et il faut savoir qu'ici on a
un bloc de charge de 39 fois alors
puisqu'on parle de notre bloc des
charges parlons justement de l'autonomie
microsoft me donne une autonomie pouvant
aller jusqu'à 13 heures alors 13 heures
peut-être pas moins autour de 10 heures
oui ça c'est sûr benevides amant ça va
dépendre une fois de plus de vous de vos
usages de ce que vous allez en faire est
ce que vous allez à faire carburer au
oui/non quoi comment bien évidemment
tout cas moi c'est une machine que je
trouve relativement bonne en autonomie
et c'est également un ordinateur que je
trouve performant alors attention
performance oui et non on va pas aller
très très loin vous avez ici un
processeur intel san intel core i5 de
10e génération vous avez la possibilité
soit d'avoir 4 gigas de ram soit d'avoir
8 gigas de ram c'est la lpddr2 4 x 4
gigas de ram s'entendent aujourd'hui un
petit peu light pour un ordinateur je
vous parlais de la configuration dans
quelques instants et on parlera aussi
des usages pour savoir si effectivement
il est fait pour vous oui ou non et
après vous avez 2 confie différentes en
termes de stockage vous avez soit 64
giga de stockage ces deux-là e mmc ça
pareil ça me paraît un peu light mais
j'ai vous détailler dans quelques
instants soit vous avez du ssd 128 go de
stockage ou 256 et gien de stockage et
côté carte graphique on a une intel uhd
question sécurité on allait puce tpm
sécurisé et où vient déverrouiller très
rapidement grâce au capteur d'empreintes
digitales one touch pour windows et
l'eau vous positionnez votre doigt là et
vous déverrouillez ça c'est bien ici on
a peut utiliser la reconnaissance
faciale avec votre webcam comme on
pourrait la voir sur un microsoft
lapdock trois formats se contenter c'est
déjà très très très bien du capteur
d'empreintes digitales qu'on ne
retrouvera pas partout pas dans toutes
les configurations on ne l'aura pas dans
la configuration 4 gigas de ram + 64 go
de stockage vous pourrez la voir dans
les deux
configuration 8 + 128,8 plus de 156 et
je vous donne les tarifs dans quelques
instants
puisque on s'en parle vous avez une
webcam en 720p avec une ouverture de f
2.0 elle ira très bien pour venir
communiquer avec vos amis skype tout la
visioconférence le télétravail tel qu'on
peut le trouver aujourd'hui on va pas
avoir ici la meilleure caméra en termes
de qualité mais une fois de plus pour
venir communiquer échanger avec vos amis
ça fera la faire si vous voulez monter
en qualité
il faudra trouver une caméra externe au
niveau de l'expérience logiciel on
tourne sur windows dix familles en mode
s ça windows disent tous cas de plus
standard le mode s c'est un mode
simplifié qui vous permettra de
télécharger des applications uniquement
depuis votre microsoft store ça viendra
vous protéger notamment pour éviter de
télécharger des applications corrompus
tu pourrais potentiellement avoir des
virus des malwares et de fait ça vous
évite de venir télécharger un antivirus
néanmoins ce mode est ce vous pouvez
désactiver très facilement pour
télécharger depuis n'importe quelle
source alors attention si vous le
téléchargez vous ne pourrez pas faire
machine arrière et le réactiver après
point également positif on a dû où il
fait ici c'est en gros cet ordinateur un
microsoft surface laptop light ils ont
bigot à la place de light
il ya un côté moins deux chiffres dans
l'appellation go que leitza suis en plus
la gamme chez microsoft
en tout cas moi ce que j'aime bien sûr
tandis naters et qu'on voit vraiment
qu'on a affaire à une machine qui va pas
être destiné aux personnes qui veulent
faire du montage vidéo qui veulent faire
de la retouche photo que faire de la 3d
ou pour les gamers on a vraiment affaire
un ordinateur qui va être là pour de la
bureautique pour la prise de notes qui
va pouvoir servir un commercial
lorsqu'il sera en déplacement pour faire
un reporting qui sera là pour des
étudiants qui sera là pour des
enseignants qui sera là pour vous à la
maison si vous la regardez du contenu en
streaming
alors vous pourrez jouer avec mais
surtout sur du contenu en cloud gaming
que ça viendra pas utiliser les
ressources de votre machine pour netflix
my canal prime vidéo pour disney et
compagnie eh bien vous aurez une machine
qui est vraiment très très bonne vous
pouvez installer bien évidemment un pack
office dessus pour gérer vos comptes
pour faire un tout vote saisi votre
bureautique on a une machine qui n'est
pas du tout axé sur la performance mais
qui est axé sur un usage quotidien
modéré un usage de tout un chacun est en
tout cas moi cette machine j'aime
beaucoup je trouve vraiment bien elle
beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup beaucoup
d'atouts et la très belle surprise là
dessus c'est vraiment la finition est de
toucher au niveau du clavier ça c'est
vraiment des points que j'aime beaucoup
et que je fais vraiment un souligné vous
en douterez c'est une machine qui n'est
absolument pas gratuite et je vais vous
parler du tarif
parce que tu arrives ces liens
effectivement je vous annonce que le
tarif de base et à 629 euros 629 euros
vous aurez une configuration sur
laquelle je ne vous conseille pas
d'aller c'est la version 4 gigas de ram
et 64 giga de stockage 4 gigas de ram je
trouve ça quand même un petit peu light
même si vous n'allez pas installer des
programmes gourmand dessus monté sur la
config supérieure à 8 gigas de ram et en
plus ça technologies de stockage ces
deux-là emc qui ne sera pas la plus
rapide mieux vaut privilégier une
technologie ssd pour ne pas se retrouver
dès fois à s'arracher les cheveux si
vous trouvez que ça rame un petit peu
trop donc la config à 629 euros malgré
tout se trouve pas extrêmement
intéressante mois là confie que je peux
bien vous conseiller c'est la 8 +128 qui
coûte 799 euros
on augmente tout de suite le tarif
néanmoins là vous avez quelque chose qui
tient vraiment la route si vous voulez
plus de stockage vous pouvez monter sur
l'a8 plus 256 ça me fait quand même
rajouter 200 euros de plus 999 euros
je pense qu'il vaut mieux être sur l'a8
+128 et avoir un petit disque ssd
externe pour venir ce toqué si vous avez
besoin puisque de toute façon vous
n'allez pas travailler sur des projets
gourmand soit de la vidéo que ce soit de
la grosse retouche photo donc vous
n'avez pas forcément besoin de 256 go de
stockage habituellement sur l'ordinateur
je déconseille de 128 go de stockage
parce que je trouve un petit peu light
mais vu l'adn de cette machine qui ne
consiste pas à stocker des fichiers
gourmand et un peu trop volumineux c'est
pas très très grave
vous allez avoir des fichiers powerpoint
des fichiers excel des fichiers word
vous allez sortir des photos tout ce que
vous allez regarder ça mais surtout être
en streaming dont vous ai pas besoin de
stocker particulièrement de choses dans
votre machine donc pour moi le 128 ira
très bien et après vous prenez un petit
disque externe qui vous coûtera un petit
peu moins de 100 euros
ça vous monte l'édition a un petit peu
moins de 900 euros et pour moi c'est la
très très bien donc c'est une machine
que j'aime bien je trouve que microsoft
a très bien bossé là dessus ça lui
permet d'étendre sa gamme avec un
produit qui est vraiment cool une très
jolie surprise
personnellement j'aime beaucoup a vous
de me dire vous maintenant ce que vous
en pensez en bas en commentaire comment
vous la trouvez cette machine on pourra
pas tout faire avec un gagne évidemment
et dites moi quels sont vos yeux
est-ce que vous c'est plus de la
bureautique est ce que vous êtes a
contrario sur de l'édition photo vidéo
fait de la 3d compagnie que sais-je
encore alors pourquoi pas des gamers
arkema tout ça en bas en commentaire et
dites-moi si elle peut vous intéresser
et si oui pour quel usage sur ceux ci
n'ont pas de gros bisous pour lé soin de
vous et à très vite m'ont beaucoup
d'amour cacao
[Musique]